today in our series world of motion we
examine the long and sometimes difficult
journey that many people make in their
search for a better life wars in Syria
and Afghanistan are driving refugees
through Turkey as they make their way to
Greece so many land on the Greek island
of Lesbos which has become the epicenter
for the country's migrant crisis Roxana
Saberi traveled there and joined the
last remaining humanitarian rescue boat
in the area helping people get across
the sea this scenic island is known for
its tourism but for many migrants and
refugees it's the gateway to a new life
here in Europe off the coast of the
Greek island of Lesbos cries for help a
dinghy has capsized flinging frightened
passengers into the sea these Afghan
migrants all survived thanks to this
small crew their name is refugee rescue
and their mission is to save lives when
people seeking safety and stability
dared to cross this perilous stretch of
water from Turkey to Greece it's about
six miles from Turkey which is right
behind us to lesbos which is right over
here
Turkey is home to the world's largest
refugee population with a crackdown on
migrants in Turkey and tough immigration
policies elsewhere in Europe the number
of people fleeing to lesbos by sea has
soared the UN says - more than 16,000 so
far this year that's the biggest influx
since 2016
as the only NGO left at lesbos with a
rescue boat Swiss space refugee rescue
is working overtime all the time we are
tired we are tired but that's that's how
our middle of the night we watched as
they helped bring dozens of Afghan
migrants to shore that's where we met
Zara and her 18 month old son much tebah
she said we had a lot of trouble
our dinghy was overcrowded and the motor
stopped working this is the dinghy they
came in on there's water in the back of
it and it looks deflated and these are a
couple of the lifejackets they were
wearing you can tell just by holding
them they're fake most of them never saw
water or don't not have to swim but are
you creating an atmosphere we're
actually encouraging more migrants and
refugees to come because they know
they'll be rescued by people like you
people did not start crossing because we
were here people are desperate and they
seek safety Oh militant bus the Passat
attorney
that's why Zahra says she fled
Afghanistan we met her again at a UN
transit camp where we saw bus loads of
Syrians Yemenis and Afghans stopped for
food and medical care Gepetto media and
I kidney shot attuned on dande shop what
would you like to say to those people
who rescued you last night she said
we're very grateful for them without
them we don't know where we would have
ended up to get an idea of just how many
people have made the dangerous journey
across the sea take a look at this tens
of thousands of life jackets discarded
on this hill in lesbos piling up to make
what's known here as the mountain of
misery for many migrants the misery
flows even onto Shore at Camp Moria
built for 3,000 people it's bursting
with 13,000 crammed into tattered tents
with no electricity in no school they
wait many many months
you went Phillip LeClair calls this
place a time bomb what about those
skeptics who say we don't have enough
space for more migrants well for
Refugees people fleeing war persecution
you have no choice
it's it's the basic human values that's
why the young volunteers at refugee
rescue say they do what they do
omid attuned Vasa is Afghan man named
fair HOD told me he attempted this
treacherous journey across the sea four
times seen a buckle though he was afraid
that they would all die on the way here
what do you feel when you rescue these
people who are making this crossing both
relief and frustration because it's
gonna be a long journey refugees still
living in camps on this island hope
their asylum requests are approved
before winter sets in in the meantime
more people keep arriving on these
shores for CBS this morning Roxana
Saberi lesbos Greece incredible footage
and yeah every time I see it I think of
that poem I'm paraphrasing here but you
don't put your child on a boat unless
the water is safer than the land it's
desperate as the conditions are in that
refugee camp it tells you how desperate
what they're fleeing is and as a matter
of historical fact we were all migrants
or descendants of migrants we've been
walking around this planet for a long
time this is what's happening today and
we take so much for granted and you see
people are literally risking their lives
to come to this country